c'est la première fois que denise push
all-in se présentait face aux
journalistes depuis la reconnaissance de
la république autoproclamée de john
yates entre temps il était lundi soir à
moscou en compagnie de vladimir poutine
mais aussi de son homologue de la
république populaire de lougansk pour
parapher ce document de reconnaissance
des deux républiques du dombass et pour
cette conférence de presse il était
accompagné du vice président du conseil
de la fédération il s'agit de la chambre
haute du parlement russe celui ci a
souligné qu'il s'agissait là d'une
décision historique
nous ne rencontrons avec vous sur le
territoire de deux nièces qu est
une décision vraiment historique a été
prise pour la reconnaissance des
républiques populaires de données skate
de lugan ce que hier la douma d'état de
la russie et le conseil de fédération
ont ratifié deux accords
je pense que c'est une date historique
denise boucher leonard outre souligné
que les évacuations de population
continuer de même que la mobilisation
générale en effet la situation est
toujours aussi critique au niveau de la
ligne de front entre les forces du
craignait et les milices des républiques
populaires du dombass il a également
tenu à clarifier les choses il n'y a pas
à l'heure actuelle de déploiement de
troupes russes dans le donbass et ce
n'est pas prévu pour le moment
actuellement il n'y a pas de troupes
russes ici avant ces événements tous les
observateurs internationaux y compris de
l'ol c'est eux les ont cherché mais ils
n'ont rien trouvé en ce qui concerne
l'avenir est il possible que les troupes
russes soient présentes ici c'est
possible quand et dans quelles
circonstances l'évolution de la
situation nous le dira
il ya près de deux semaines de nice
pauline se présenter en conférence de
presse habillés en costume cravate et
cette fois aujourd'hui ils étaient
habillés en treillis kaki alors c'est là
qu'on mesure tout ce qui s'est passé en
l'espace de quelques jours entre
l'escaladé militaire la mobilisation
générale l'évacuation de la population
et enfin la reconnaissance des
territoires du dombass par la russie au
final un véritable emballement des
événements